welcome to what World Championship the
match chess stuff something today we're
going to talk about game 10 of one of
the finest matches last reversal
selector 1910 and claw if you look on
the board here and you see better than I
do
there's actually a picture here before
game 1 okay they dressed up better now
than we do in this class okay and then
how you want to talk about how you're
dressed at home who okay good dinners no
children here all right now this match
was quite complicated because even today
we well they don't argue about the moves
although I'm gonna argue about them they
argue about what the rules of the match
were many people throughout the decades
and scores have concluded incorrectly I
believe that Schlachter needs to win by
two
in fact this article on this random web
page that has no you know semblance of
being correct but I'm going to go by
anyway it seems like in some of the
negotiations they were talking about
really long matches 2030 games and in
those instances I think they wanted
somebody to win by two and if they
didn't they would just keep playing one
of the things I read here was that if it
was a tied match the arbiter would
declare the winner what anyway yeah you
won you play better okay so anyway my
understanding based on what I've read
which may not be true it was it was just
a normal match and if Schlachter had
drawn the last game which he could have
easily done would have been the world
champion okay but he didn't so he wasn't
and a lot of people have heard of
selector because of the variation he
played the slob defense with black which
actually he played in this game now also
weird about this match based on again
this crazy website is that some of the
games took several days
they would play for 3 4 or 5 hours that
they take a break then ply the next day
play a few more hours take a break now
I've done this too but I really do the
world championships won't championships
in the 70s and 80s and 90s they would
adjourn and they would play it off
tonight this has happened but I didn't
know they did in the 1910 so anyway it's
not clear who was analyzing the end
games or who had better help or whatever
anyway if you want to read about it
there's a lot of places on the web to
read about this match and I'm still not
100% sure as to the rules but it seems
like the rules as to what they were the
Schleck sure could have won this match
and he would have been the world
champion the match ended in a tie and so
since last year was the world champion
here we change his title which is
normally what they do now sometimes they
have tiebreaks but usually not ok now
they played half the games in one city
half the games in another city which
they've also done recently to usually
try to get all in one place
and after nine games then the 10th game
was played in berlin i selectra had one
win and there were a draws so I guess
the players were pretty equally matched
and throughout my life it's been argued
selected he gets a win the last game to
win the match by 2 but I don't believe
that
I think if selectra had drawn this game
he would have been the world champion ok
and of course laster lost the world
championship years later to kappa blanka
and then Kevin Lika had the title stolen
from him ok so you said get into
politics oh there you go
alright so they started with a Slav I
thought they did not the game ended in
one move but that's worse than usual
usually I have I have better times with
making the moves okay
well we'll get rid of this board so that
Bensimon is happy ok and with 71 moves
it wasn't zero okay there we go and they
started with the Slav defense and well
in fact the
very issue that selector plays I also
play now and I had white and black just
not at the same time okay now in this
position which is very common today many
many many thousands of Grandmaster games
black can play Bishop f5 dish of g4 pawn
to e6 or well also a6 now or the
selector Schlag which is fog which is
what I play g6 so you should play the
OPA named after you that's good idea ok
and white and black develop their pieces
in castle so it doesn't look like a game
played 150 years ago only 100 years ago
ok 93 and again I've had this position
with white and black Bishop d3 is a move
that's played today that's fine
ok now now the game starts to look like
1910 because they start playing a little
iffy ok
there's 2 moves the grandmasters play
here castles is the most common and h3
to prevent Bishop g4 is also I've also
faced white played Queen c2 which is not
a move anybody would play now in fact
the Queen's probably not even well
placed on c2 so black has two ideas
black and play Knight a six to play
Knight d4 attacking the Queen and Bishop
probably better is to just play C 5 as
quickly as possible and we'll have sort
of a grünfeld
where White's played III and Queen seeds
here which wouldn't play either move so
black is already about equal but ok this
is 19 cents I won't complain about the
opening too much the point of Queen c2
from last report of view is that if
black plays Bishop g4 this pins the
Knights of the Queen so now if you play
Bishop g4 why could just play 95 and
there is no pen that was Lasker's idea
anyway okay so night a6 was played
that's okay and a3 now turned out many
years later Alekhine the future world
champion at this position with black and
played knight c7 and he won and the
purpose of 97
quite funny black may want to play 98
and night to d6 and possibly Bishop f5
and his Knights control you for and
pretty well-placed
okay selector took on c4 and
unfortunately when I looked at the game
from the source I had people had
commented on the game people like Lasker
and collector and kappa blanka and other
players who didn't have the engines that
i had so some of their comments were
suspicious they were saying this is much
better for black this is winning for
white when the opposite was true but I
put my own notes to the game so we
actually have some correct notes which
is good okay and here
well actually definitely try to get c5
in at some point and we'll just have
some sort of Grunfeld position where
White's not playing very aggressively
okay instead he played something that I
would play when I was an expert so maybe
about the level here this game b5 and b4
okay a ously white doesn't want to take
this pawn because then blacks
Knight finally comes to b4 and he'll get
White's Bishop so white plays Knight to
a4 and this pawn structure for black is
very weakening and for my higher rated
students I call this the accordion pawn
structure according to who me
okay because these pawns aren't really
defending each other they don't make a
pawn chain and there's a lot of
weaknesses so I I don't like this idea
of b5 be for blacks pawns are too weak
okay he took on a3 again he wants to
play Knight to b4 so white took back and
prevented night before and Bishop e7
defends the pawn now there was a very
strange note I was playing a one-minute
game or a five-minute game or a slow
game I would make this move pretty
quickly which lasker played and one of
the commentators said this is a bad move
and I was thinking that's a bad move so
I put it on my engine the engine said
it's the best move so very suspicious
white played rook to b1 and White's rook
is on an open B file and it's attacking
the ship and the rooks much better on b1
that a1 it has many more squares and it
gets off this dangerous diagonal so it
would be one just like a no-brainer move
but the commentator didn't like it okay
and black played Queen c7 defending his
bishop and white did make a mistake here
95 computer actually wants to go crazy
with h4 h5 okay
95 I don't like because I don't think
White's ready to get a big attack yet
White's King is still on a1 so I don't
like when my Kings on e1 and my
opponents castle that I'm doing lots of
aggressive stuff okay
and now there's a lot of notes black
ended up playing Knight h5 in this game
as many people have pointed out black
played super aggressively never played
the safest move and people are thinking
well if you needed a draw to win the
match why is he playing so crazy and
some people said that he gets more prize
money if he wins by two points at one
point I don't believe that I don't think
so and some thought he wanted to win by
two points so the victory was decisive
not win with 9 draws yeah I think he
just was playing chess this is the best
rule that's something I'm going to make
if it's crazy it's crazy okay so that H
Phi is very aggressive opening up this
bishop and speaking of aggressive g4
what a crazy move but last your head
should win this game it's high to match
so white playing crazy I don't yeah f4
sort of a solid move defending the
knight computer likes f4 okay g4 takes
now if you take the bishop black and
play nine g7e six is a good square and
the e5 pawn is hanging so last year
decided to take the night instead the
districts attacked on e5 he retreated it
trade on g6 very complicated position
both Kingston get attacked I don't like
the way this Knight is I don't like
where this Knight is this Bishop is
blocked by a pawn but potentially this
could happen so very crazy position okay
white play Queen c4 and the idea is
twofold
we're pitting the pawn so we're going to
play Bishop takes g6 or is in the game
Rick g1 takes g6 and we have a little
tactics over here we're attacking all
these pieces so in some variations
White's taking the bishop and then
taking the knight with his queen
so Queen c4 very aggressive and this is
actually quite funny black play Bishop
c8
stopping rep takes bishop and the
annotator said exclamation mark what a
great move and I was like that's a great
move I was get a little suspicious so I
turn down my engine and it's like that's
that's no good
yeah okay so the engine line is actually
to play C 5 and then you're attacking
the rook on h1 so Rick g1 Queen h2 is a
move and they're showing how White's
winning because White's winning just a
tall white swimming okay so but I can't
do any of this because this pawn is
pinned this is pinned this is it's
hacked and this is attacked and White's
not down any material okay and that's
correct white is winning but White's not
winning because c5 is a bad move c5 is a
good move White's winning because he
plied this terrible move Queen h2 since
this queen is pinning this pawn black
should just play e6 and now we we can't
play rook takes g6 because it's just
hanging on and the computer gives a
crazy line and says equal which is rook
takes b7 Queen takes takes takes and
black has a rook and upon for two pieces
I don't see why either side would be too
unhappy here nobody's getting checkmate
or anything and says like something like
point zero one some some evaluation
where it's equal although the annotators
didn't give the movie 6 they gave them
move queen h2 which just losses and said
whites winning I mean they're right but
you're making a bad move for black okay
so Bishop c8 was plighted the game and
white made a mistake he played work g1
probably h4 is the best move trying to
attack blacks king and queen a5 track
was played which I don't think it's a
very good move Queen takes h2 is
interesting work takes g6 again we can't
take the rook because of this pen Queen
h1 check is analysis but my engine was
saying 97 is the best move the Knights
terrible on a6 now the bishop can go to
e6 or a6 the knight can go to e6 the
knight can go to d5 and the computer
says it's equal and some of the moves
they give instead are just losing for
black okay so Rick g1 not the best move
Queen a5 check not the best move it's
okay Bishop d2 and the Queen goes to d5
and we could have seen an endgame
instead we saw a really crazy middle
game lucky for us and actually the move
the engine says is best nobody has ever
mentioned okay and that is to get this
night off of the rim teachers are always
telling you guys night on the rim is dim
but then when the Knights around the rim
they leave them there the whole game so
computers suggest the move Knight c3
attacking the Queen and getting the
Knights to a better square maybe to e4
later
rook see ones okay okay Knight c3 here
with white having an advantage instead
white played Queen c2 Queen h5 and last
year when sort of crazy here now
strategically why it's doing really well
here because these pieces are really
silly
we could play rugby one and we have a
lot of pressure on these pieces the
knight could come to c5 later or efore
and again these pieces are just terrible
instead Laster went all in okay
he sacrificed his bishop on g6 and then
Queen age 2 was played well he's taking
the bishop later he could take attacking
the rook and the idea is white isn't
really sacrificing a piece because after
takes white plays Queen b3 check
and attacks the bishop on b7 black gets
out of check and the bishop these two
pieces are hanging so he plays rook f8
putting tremendous pressure on f2 so if
white takes that night he might get
checkmated rook takes f2 and instead he
played Queen to b3 and Queen b3 pins the
rook to the king so there's no good rook
move King h8 I'm pinning the rook and F
for stopping rook F 2 and if we count
them and cheering all the materials
equal both Kings are sort of in bad
positions and both Knights are sort of
not so good and when I know why his
positions like this with my dad years
and years and years ago
he would say both both sides stand badly
both sides have a bad position now
yesterday I was having a chess
discussion with my roommate who happens
to work at the chess club and she
posited that trading Queens is bad and I
said it's bad for you and she said yeah
and I said is it bad for your opponent
too
she didn't mean in a position she's been
in general and general don't trade
Queens is bad I was like well if you're
trading Queen is I must be in your
opponent's trading Queens so it's bad
for both of you so I mean it's not
likely that a move is bad for both sides
I guess it's possible I just don't know
how ok so here I think white would want
to trade Queens don't think White's
going to lose this head again all right
so black played the move g5 given an
exclamation mark by the annotator
although I think e 5 is also very
interesting and it's important to note
this pawn can't capture because rook
takes rook mate and there would be a new
world champion
okay so g5 Queen to d3 was played
attacking the knight on a6 pawn takes
pawn sacrificing the knight and if you
take the knight
takes on up now blacks threatening rook
takes rook pawn takes Queen takes
checkmate okay the game could be made
any second Ben Simon better come back
it could be checkmate others Ben Simon
okay so instead of getting checkmated
white recapture on f4 and this pretty
funny position it's sort of a middle
game but it's very late in the game and
both Kings are a little suspicious and
we got all isolated pawns so it's not
clear who's King is more exposed
who's Knight is worse whose pawn
structures worse okay Queen h4 check and
the king went to e2 although I think the
computer slightly prefers running this
way but King e2 is okay and white played
rook f2 if white plays King e1 and we
repeat the position and the game would
enter the draw I think select review the
world champion and I don't think Blaster
wanted select to be the world champion
so I'll ask reply trick f2 and let's
keep playing
Queen h5 check and now he played rook f3
again if we play Queen f3 which the
computer says is a reasonable move this
would be a really funny perpetual and
the idea is if you don't play Queen d3
and just move your king you're losing
your knight what you can't do
however if black takes the knight here
then white has sort of a nice attack
with queen h7 coming so probably blacks
not going to do that okay well Cora so
Queen f3 probably a draw with correct
play white doesn't want to draw because
then his opponent's the role champion so
he played rook f3 and now this is a very
funny point in the game black played 9
c7 and now white missed a very
interesting move which according to my
computer gives them a slight advantage
and nobody mentioned it usually in the
notes of the game one of the players or
one of the nsa's mentions this move of
course rook h3 looks like it pins the
Queen of the King except that it's
illegal because you'd be in
check so there's a crazy move which
allows you to play rook h3 you rip h1
which nobody mentioned my computer likes
it you have to take the rock we fork the
king and queen and this positions two
rooks for a queen but the computer
prefers Wyatt in this position slightly
although even if White's saw this
variation which I'm guessing he did he
might have thought it was more likely a
draw than a win so we better not drop as
they are opponents of the world champion
again okay but the computer would have
played rook h1 but that might have led
to a draw it's probably better to have a
worse position and have winning chances
then draw the game and your opponent or
world champion okay so he played rook
takes c6 which is not a good move and
black played Knight to b5 threatening a
huge fork I know what that's called it's
too many pieces I'm too confused
so rook c4 it says exclamation mark
although I think the computer prefers
moving the king somewhere but then with
the idea of rook h3 so I think king u1
is the computer move all right
so rook c4 even the computer is playing
better than Lasker as far as the
strength of the moves it's so important
that Lasker doesn't draw that maybe
we'll ask her did was better make the
game go on and on and on and hope that
select your blunders okay and he did
blunder here he played rip takes f4 the
computer gives a move nobody's ever
given Queen g4 and it says Black has a
big advantage and Knight d6 is what the
commentators gave and they like blacks
position because White's King seems a
little funny and this rook seems pinned
this pawns weak this nights out of play
so the computers and the commentators
prefer black but he played rook takes up
4 going for the quick kill Bishop takes
rook takes now we have a lot of pressure
here on d4 ok
and the rook is pinned to the king so
black has a big attack unfortunately for
black I don't know if you missed this
move I don't know
but white played rook c8 track and we
can't play King age 7 it's illegal and I
mean retreating the rook doesn't see I
mean okay so this ship FA and King f2 on
pins very nice move
now the rooks not pinned and these were
the kinds of positions where it seemed
possible selector could have repeated
the position by checking a lot but
decided not to do so and they were
thinking why do you do that but it's
actually not so easy to repeat so he
played he played Queen h2 and correctly
one of the few times the imitators were
correct it happens sometimes even when
I'm doing it they were explaining White
Queen h4 lost because the point of Queen
h4 is to play queen g4 and win this rook
okay but a force that doesn't work
rook g3 Queen's legs rook Queen g6 and
whites threatening Queen g8 mate and I'm
sure Rick h3 check is winning and whites
winning so correctly select your play
Queen h2 the King moved out of check and
now the it seems likely Queen h4 would
have drawn the game and they give all
these variations in some of them black
wins and some of them were draws either
way selectors the world champion a funny
trick would be something like this and
then after Queen takes we fork the king
and queen so something like that could
happen okay where we could move back and
forth and draw in black would be the
world champion so it seems likely if you
had play Queen h4 check in this position
probably would have been the world
champion one move changing the history
of chess instead you play queen h1 check
and now Rick f1 of course if you play
King II - we could play rook takes rook
and Knight takes d4 check again winning
the Queen but maybe he didn't see rook
f1 or underestimated it we got to be
careful because this Bishop is pinned
and it's attacked
there's x-rays everywhere there a doctor
here so ok Queen check again white runs
away if you take to win the Queen which
was not played check check you can't
play King here because it's illegal
there's a queen on d3 and Rick h7 wins
and wreck a chain twins winning the
Queen on h4 so black didn't do that
black played Rick takes f1 Queen takes
f1 Queen takes d4 check the game still
complicated Queen d3 again black needs
to win doesn't look like he's going to
win anymore
looks like he might draw well he wasn't
able to do that either
and white is up a rook for a bishop and
a pawn black has a lot of checks and in
this position I think he made the losing
move he played them a queen bee to check
was of this position er later yeah I
think he should play no no Queen B to
check is right
yeah I was later I think he made the
losing move ok in this position when
he's checking a lot yeah queen g4 check
I think loses the Queen d4 this is the
best square on the board for the White
Queen
it stops checks and it protects the rook
the best move is Queen g2 which attacks
the rook and now we're going to check
from behind the a pawn and try to keep
checking you forever now black has good
drawing chances on the other hand a draw
is the same as a loss because he won't
try no actually good drawing chances
means he would win the match because he
was a point ahead so after Queen g2
Lasker had chances to draw with
perpetual check
by attacking the rook but after forcing
White's Queen to d4
now now White's pieces are in the center
totally dominating and his king is safe
the King is much safer behind the a pond
than in front of it we has almost no
shelter and it's near the Black Knight
which near the Black Knight sometimes
white gets checkmated when the Kings on
a2 there's a pawn in front of it and
this Knight has nowhere to go now
White's King is pretty safe so well the
game didn't take too much longer now but
black made another mistake later of
trading Queens going into a loss end
game but I think based on the moves that
I saw we're going to look at the rest of
the game in a second I think based on
white seeming to avoid a draw in more
than one instance I think it's pretty
clear
Lasker had to win this game and I think
selectra might have gotten carried away
thinking he was winning maybe he was
winning and decided to play for win
instead of a draw when a draw would have
made him the world champion so this idea
that selector had to win by two points
in a ten game match I don't believe it
that doesn't seem fair you know unless
I'm playing like my camera then it's
fair but now as for all championship
match now Fischer had a similar idea
he thought the Challenger should win by
two points but he wanted unlimited
number of games so he wanted the first
to win ten games but if it was nine to
nine that he would still be the champion
as ten to nine isn't enough of a victory
if he played Karpov a match first to win
10 games they'd still be playing the
Fischer would still be alive today
they'd be on gain over 11,000 now with
eight wins to seven and nine thousand
nine hundred and seventy five draws okay
so luckily that didn't happen it should
happen later we did have an unlimited
match and that match actually didn't end
that's how limited it was the World
Chess Federation president said that's
enough
they first to win six games and after 48
games W won six games yet and they said
okay that's enough of that now the games
are finite and you know if it's could be
a ten game match a 12 game match a 20
ten gave me that she was a little short
that doesn't seem like a long enough
match but it was nineteen ten okay so
white made sure he never got checked and
King was safe and this position after
Queen f5 check notice Knight takes Queen
is illegal because it's pinned and here
black made a move which kappa blanka
gave a question mark - which i finally
agree kind of entually black needs to
keep everything on the board with some
drawing chances but after the Queen
trade now there's going to be a win so
probably should play King to d8 or King
to e8 and there's some perpetual checks
there's some tactical tricks now there's
no tricks now not white should win
pretty easily and he did and this game
was adjourned twice and it took many
many hours so Lasker earned his World
Championship okay and in the view of
some people the selector was a better
player than last turn would have been
world champion a long time yeah kappa
blanka would have taken care of him
anyway okay but you know anybody who's
played in chess tournaments for years
knows about Emanuel Lasker he was world
champion for over 25 years
he played many World Championship
matches and they sort of barely heard of
Carl Schlachter yeah he drew a mansion
in some opening but probably from you
know 1908 to 1927 a superior player but
it's not like now there's a World
Championship match every week you play
the world champion if you played too
well he'd find somebody he could beat
easier I mean like I played too well he
was ahead of me most of the time I'm
gonna play you know Marazzi and chigorin
and I'll show them who the boss is okay
and Alec kind did that as well actually
be kappa blanka he tried to find people
he could beat and he couldn't even beat
hurva because he was too drunk but when
he sobered up then he was fine
okay so Ricky - and white walked his
King up
and in this position black resigned
Lasker tied to match the match was a
draw one win each with eight draws and
they last year maintained his title now
I'll just write a book recently that
I've read many times but it's been about
ten years called the view from the top
and that is the match between Anand and
Kasparov play at the World Trade Center
in 1995 and they actually did plan
September 11th also but in that match
the first eight games were drawn Anand
won game nine and then Anan got crushed
so I think ten games isn't really enough
to decide who's the better player is if
that match ended after nine games a nod
would have been the world champion if it
ends after ten games they would have
tied the match but they played 17 games
at between games 9 and 17 a non loss
like five or six of them just kept
losing losing losing losing okay and I
think anything between 16 to 24 games is
a very reasonable amount of time to
decide who's the better player is ten
games it's sort of a coin toss you're
going to have a lot of draws and then
somebody's going to win a game and
they're their world champion especially
when the world champion gets draws then
the short match really gives them a big
advantage because the way chess is
nowadays even in the one-sided Carlson
anan matches
we're not like didn't win any games
those games were still all draws there's
a lot of draws and you know Carlson's
winning two or three games and winning
the match he's not winning fun you know
that could be 1800s when they played ten
game matches sometimes it was like eight
wins and two draws because it was sort
of a mismatch but nowadays when it isn't
mismatch that means you won two and drew
eight and they're like how's the other
guy playing he's terrible I'm like what
he lost two games to zero what do you
mean so yeah things were different back
then this match was sort of more of a
modern match almost all the games were
drawn and selector losing the last game
the only game of the match that he lost
when he was probably winning
indefinitely drawing cost him the world
championship title so we could all shut
it to your for Karl but I can still play
this
to Slav and I'll still lose with it like
I always do all right thank you for the
World Championship match coming to my
lecture and I'll see everybody next week